okay
it's monday
one of our favorite things to do yeah
zach's already drunk
what do you say should i just watch this
i'm joking you're like way ahead of us
man yeah yeah zach sent me a message
earlier that he had watched this show
and one of the funny things i laughed
out loud when he said um he's like one
the actual mom and the actress that
played the mom had like really really
tragic hair in this which i agree they
did and also
uh he's like when the paranormal team
got there the wiccans
when the wiccans got there
uh the the main like uh lady of the
wickens like on the show was like super
hot and then it's like the real one
looked like e.t he said
i was like that's some gay victory right
well she was a little older you know
what i mean she was always she was an
old uh older woman who was uh looking
very uh skinny and uh
yeah she probably was cute yeah they put
like a young hot
woman in there like i said it's weird
because they do that a lot sometimes i
know that a haunting they tend to have
like a stable of actors because you see
like the same ones like turning up again
and again
so a lot of times i'm sure they're just
like hey we need somebody to play the
mom you don't like anything like that
but whatever but sometimes they get it
like pretty spot-on so i'm always kind
of like it so
they are obviously like trying to get
somebody but if they can't they're just
like yeah you'll do just like get in
there no one's gonna like worry too much
about this is a good episode what's good
about this episode is it's an
entertaining episode to watch okay
but what's interesting about the case is
that
the mom who's kind of like
the most interested in the case actually
tries to solve it she's doing her own
paranormal kind of
[ __ ] uh
paranormal research she's actually
marking down when things happen and what
time and what was going on like what was
the weather like outside and how was
everybody feeling that right and also so
she's actually documenting it yeah
that's good that's real good um of
course i haven't seen the documentation
that's just talked about in the program
so it may not be anywhere near as
detailed as they make it seem in the in
the episode but it's interesting that
that she's actually kind of doing the
right thing and documenting what what
happens when
what was the family's second stage and
the environmental conditions as well
which like i said that could play into
it she seemed very uh level-headed and
she said she was a very scientific
person and she wanted to like and i was
like well that's good that's what you
should do it lends credibility to the
case if you if it's well documented
over time and you can see the documents
and [ __ ] verify that it actually that
she actually did document it you know i
mean it's just kind of adds a little
more error credibility to it i'd like to
see it i'd like to see her the actual
stuff that she wrote down and
but um it's
it's an interesting case
yes it's got wiccans in it
they all showed up
and [ __ ] this one was a little bit
different for a couple of reasons one
the ghosts i
didn't really get the feeling that the
ghosts were all that malevolent
like it was creepy the stuff that was
happening but it wasn't kind of like oh
you got a dark entity or a demon or
anything like that it was there was a
[ __ ] ton of ghosts in the house uh
evidently but none of them were really
mean some of them were just kind of like
scary and they actually called wiccans
to
cleanse the house of the of the uh
infestation i uh classified this case as
one of the one of the portal type cases
where there's a portal to the other side
a bunch of ghosts that are lost and
maybe like a malevolent one usually
that's usually the case that's in there
that's kind of manipulating some of them
and they gotta try to close the portal
and tell them all to go home that kind
of thing yeah
go to the summer lanes that's the way
you say yeah there's many cases like
this and this is you know i call them a
portal case
a lot of times when we talk about the
portal
and the multitude of ghosts that sounds
dirty yeah
[Laughter]
you can make an x-rated version of it
belladonna started and then my ass was
haunted yeah there was that's and that
that is absolutely a real belladonna
it's called my ass is haunted yeah yeah
she knew all about the portal yeah
so
the portal dang
ah funny
[Laughter]
what happened well when they start
talking about
usually the portal subjects don't really
come into play until paranormal
investigators or wiccans or something
like that comes in and they say well
there's a lot of them here so there must
be a portal open
you know that's typically why somebody
left a portal yeah they left the dab
door open just like leaving the fridge
door were you born in a barn they must
have been playing with the ouija board
and they played the ouija board and left
the door open it's usually the story or
they were doing some dark arts and they
left the damn door open
so it's just one of those kind of
stories
it is yeah although like i said i don't
feel like they went too much into like
they didn't go too much into like
blaming some people like playing it
there before and all yeah they didn't
really do that so much yeah i don't
really know you know my personally well
we'll get into it in the case but
personally
i'm skeptical of these kind of stories
about the portals doesn't necessarily
mean i'm skeptical about the phenomena
phenomena could happen all right but it
might not be portals it might be
poltergeist or it might be haunting
but you know what i mean if i can people
are going to make their own explanation
of why
you know it does different things and it
seems like more than one of them you
know
might be your interpretation of what's
happening is that there's more than one
of them you know or you you see a bunch
of
apparitions but you know
if you're a ghost you can appear
anything you want to do you know
i mean i would imagine what that would
be half the fun of being a ghost yeah i
think and you might be seeing let's just
say for instance let's think about this
you might be seeing the memories of a
ghost
or a ghost might just be tripping you
out and you're imagining that that's
what that ghost looked like you know it
could be a lot of things or it could be
somebody just straight up lying
yeah paranormal investment like i said
it could totally be like what happened
in beetlejuice where the maitlands were
just trying to scare the dietzes away so
they were like what's the weirdest thing
so they pulled their faces all [ __ ] up
right yeah that's not what they look
like but that was what they were they
thought that would be scarier right than
what they actually looked like i'm
connor
i'm kind of of the opinion that
i've never seen what they would
typically call a ghost
i've seen a poltergeist and i've been in
a bad house that bad house i'd probably
call it a very mild haunting but never
saw anything
i'm of the opinion that
ghosts are very rare very rare
the chances you've just seen one of them
is [ __ ] you'd probably have to live a
couple lifetimes before you'd see one
you know the average person doesn't see
one
so what's the chances of seeing 20 of
them in one spot
you know it seems a little uh it's a
little bit like a little ghost heavy
that was more likely that it was just
one of whatever it was and
you're interpreting it as if there's a
bunch of them where it's making you
believe that there's a bunch of them
something like that thank you sebastian
thank you smash we've got a super chat
super chats and flash bulbs because
if super chats are active and of course
we always would accept a tip during the
live stream sure we like that jenny
works hard for this and let's go ahead
and everybody's drinking zach says he's
in here now i can't believe they did a
whole shut up woman i'm watching the
game but i know right they did it
okay well that's when she was trying to
do the diary and she's like hey honey
like what were you doing when you saw
that thing like i'm writing it down and
he's like i'm trying to watch that game
yeah but i was like oh my god
i understand the sentiment
i understand the sentiment but i was
never a sports ball fan you know what i
mean i never really got why people dudes
would get so wrapped up in that [ __ ]
first of all those aren't your teams
somebody else owns them okay and and why
are you cheering these dudes on is it
some kind of man lust because you can't
you're not that athletic
because when i look at those dudes that
are into sports ball
they're always [ __ ] physically unfit
almost always the ones that are really
really into it it's like they're living
vicariously
but yeah i think that's largely i'm not
like [ __ ] on sports fans as a whole
but i do kind of feel like that's a big
part of it yeah it's these
beta or dudes that used to play sports
back in high school and [ __ ] like that
and now they're kind of like too out of
shape to do it so bundy
yeah it's like an album but
most of them were betas back in the day
and they're baited
short fat beta white males
[ __ ] living vicariously through
dominant
strong black men you know what i mean
there's something weird it's a whole
thing it's so something well that's the
thing it wouldn't be weird that they
were it wouldn't be weird if they didn't
make it weird yeah yeah it's like why
don't you just accept just admit it what
it is that you're doing
that's right and then it wouldn't be
weird it would it would be fine yeah it
would be okay yeah it's just the fact
that you're like denying that that's
what it is that's what it is though
they're fetishizing
they're role-playing and fetishizing and
fantasizing that that was them see
that's why i think that they were
friends with those dudes and there
that's why i think you might like that
uh that jordan peel movie get out
because they're almost kind of like yeah
like fetishizing like yeah athletic
black people
one day he's at his house shaq shows up
to his house and they [ __ ] hit it off
they become best friends and they start
making out they never know i don't know
what the [ __ ]
then they go right
it's not weird they're making it weird
by denying it yeah oh yeah okay anyway
zack's getting interested in sex
blackfrog said have you guys heard
marilyn manson's celebrity ghost stories
episode it's [ __ ] wild yeah i heard
it but i forgot about it yeah we did see
that didn't we
was in new orleans because i used to
live in new orleans i can't remember
what all happened but i think we did
watch it but it was like a year a year
ago zach says they left a portal open in
my ass
[Laughter]
zack's calling him and he's sucking them
in with [ __ ] psycho and then
danny rowling said at first seeing the
father face down ass up trapped on the
bed actually in this episode yeah we'll
get into that with like the sheets and
everything that's right uh i for sure
it's not a spectral fleece johnson booty
warrior system yeah yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] ladies
i know what i am oh my god yeah
danny rowling also said nice looking
house in this episode okay
now through my sleuthery
i
found the actual house
um
i don't really know if i want to say
where it is because it was pretty easy
to find to be honest with you
um and the only reason that it was easy
for me to find was because i don't know
if anybody noticed but they actually
said what the name of the street was on
the episode it was just kind of like an
offhand comment but my little ears went
and i wrote it down in my notes so then
i looked it up and i was like oh that
street is like super short there's only
like 10 houses on it maybe a dozen so i
looked it up and like obviously it's not
the house that's in the episode which is
much nicer than the actual one
um but i kind of went up and down the
street and i said you know what i bet
it's that one and then i looked it up
and it you know how i found it is that
one because that family evidently still
lives there
so the guy's dad's name the the dad's
name um came up under like a white pages
or something like that and it came up on
that street and i was just kind of like
oh well
there's the house so you can look right
at it yeah
uh four bedroom four bath i think built
in 1790. if you put your mind to it you
can find most of these places that are i
mean and i don't usually like go to that
lengths but i was curious because just
because they said the street when i
looked at the street it was like really
short and so i got to curious like to
see if like i was like oh is the house
that they use on the show like on the
same street because they do that
sometimes it's not um it might be in the
same area i didn't really like exploring
that much but take them from around that
area though yeah because this is vermont
so i imagine that i imagine that house
is nearby but it's not on the same
street though it's not on the same same
street not that i saw but like i said
the street is super short it's literally
like well
there's like kind of like a brick
building like at the end and there's
like a t-junction and then it's like a
little short street with like a dirt
thing at the end and then there's like
maybe i think it's maybe 12 houses maybe
maybe not even that many but the one
that i thought that it was
that was the one that it ended up being
and like i said i'm pretty sure
at least according to the white pages
that i could find that the same family
still lives there like all this time
later because actually they bought it
in and zillow says it's not for sale
so i'm imagining and like i said on the
white pages like their names still come
up so i'm imagining they still own it
they bought it in 2005 and then moved in
in 2006. mike's saying that bit is a
weird term for me i guess he must be a
sports fan look yeah i understand the
[ __ ] channel's got a sense of humor
okay
it's not a one size fits all that type
situation but i'm just saying i did the
dudes that i knew attended and i gotta
say
my dad was bad bit that way
he would sit there and watch [ __ ]
football games and i was just like what
the [ __ ] my dad was in a nascar and he
would [ __ ] root
for [ __ ] uh the saints
you know and that was in another state
over because mississippi didn't have a
team
you know
he was just wrapped up in the [ __ ]
center it never occurred to me and i was
just like
and i couldn't stand the sound of a damn
football game i can't either actually i
don't like any of that kind of sound of
like television we're talking it's just
bad because like i said when i was
growing up my dad used to watch nascar
he didn't usually watch football except
for like
he'd watch the super bowl but normally
he didn't really get that much of a [ __ ]
about it but he he loved [ __ ] nascar
now i had other
relatives that were really into football
like i had some relatives that were
really into like college football which
i thought was bizarre but um and it was
like a college that they neither of them
went to so i thought that was a little
strange but um but yeah so they were
like super into it and they go all the
games and stuff so a lot of times like
it'd be on
like if we went to somebody's family's
house for thanksgiving or something and
i was just kind of like that like after
the 90s i was just kind of like yeah i'm
gonna go in the back bedroom and watch
mystery science theater turkey day
marathon bye i don't really want to like
be listening to like [ __ ] sports ball
um zack says oh god if you guys could
see my dad watching the colts you can't
hear that man screaming you can hear
that man screaming across the entire
house
i might have been i don't get it i might
have been genetically closer to his my
dad's dad my grandfather i never met him
he died in his [ __ ] early 40s
[ __ ]
pissed off [ __ ] rooting somebody on
over a damn boxing match on television
get it get him get him to get in any
[ __ ] call this called his wife my
grandmother because
i don't feel so good give me glad can
you get me a glass of water and [ __ ]
she got a glass of water he came back he
was on the ground she called the [ __ ]
ambulance and he was dead
heart attack
that's crazy yeah
i mean he [ __ ] root so
well he died rooting over he died doing
fight yeah what he loved yes
yeah watching black dudes beat each
other up probably
he was getting all into it [ __ ]
didn't i guess i guess he got like a
little excited yeah
about it
but uh he was yeah he was evidently
[ __ ] hilarious though he was in good
shape
so it must
then back in those days they didn't do
autopsies they just went yeah died of
something heart attack that well oh well
they're not in mississippi you know he
was upper middle class too
and uh
[ __ ] uh worked for the city which was
upper middle class [ __ ] well i mean
that's the thing though and it's like
yeah you can
have some kind of heart defect obviously
it's better to like you know try to eat
right and don't smoke and blah blah blah
you know and try to keep in shape like
obviously it's better to do that like
your odds are better but you also don't
know what the [ __ ] else could be lurking
in there like he was just dropped dead
he wasn't fat he worked for the park
well like i said i had to put all the
damn [ __ ] water pipes in and
everything him and his crew and he'd
supervise all the crew and [ __ ] like
that and he was doing uh he was doing
all the surveying and stuff
and uh he was in good shape um died
now it was southern
diet
they drank bacon grease and all i eat
all kinds of crazy [ __ ]
but he wasn't getting fat or anything so
it couldn't have been that bad
it had to people later on my dad later
on my dad said that
he thought because my dad was at home a
time he was a kid
he said looking back on it he must have
had some kind of congenital heart defect
yeah it could have been yeah i mean
that's the thing like i had an uncle who
was in really good shape he was like he
was thin like muscular stuff like that
ate right exercise stuff like that he
was dead at 32 brain tumor brain tumor
yeah so anything anything can happen
that's what i mean
um
a lot of it is genetics yeah we knew
this big tall pretty ass
girl from the club she could have been a
damn model as tall as she was long
platinum blonde hair
died of a brain tuber 28 28 at a drop of
a hat one minute she's there the next
thing we heard she's in the hospital two
days later dead
brain tumor
they didn't know
well and our friend kaylee was 34. yeah
cancer ate her up
yeah and she died of cancer yeah cute
cute yeah we had a we had a 28 year old
friend too that yeah died of a brain
tumor katie was our little lesbian
daughter
she was a mooch
mooch but we we liked her though she was
[ __ ] cute she was good she was she
was well she wasn't like obnoxious no
she wasn't obnoxious she's just like i
had some food can i have this again i
mean you didn't have to she wouldn't get
upset if you said no yeah she could can
you put me in here can i can i come to
the club because she didn't have a car
she'd have a car
but you know
it was on the way yeah so i didn't
really mind but yeah but she was fun she
died when she was 34. but yeah so we've
known a lot of people that died young
that seemed like
they were in
decent shape like you wouldn't know
looking at him that there was anything
wrong no i mean kaylee was a little half
mexican
mexican-american girl she was uh i've
told her i showed you pictures before
she had maybe what
four ten
maybe 85 pounds yeah she's tiny tiny
tiny little person wear little cat
costumes and stuff tiny little person
yeah
yeah it was it was just out of the blue
yeah i mean
it was yeah it's sad yeah it just
happens oh i don't want to don't want to
dwell on it yeah don't bring everybody
down yeah uh mike says you two are great
for me when i'm down oh that's nice
we're glad that we're like cheering
people out buck up man buck up just it's
all good we'll get through it i mean
that's right well that's why i try to
keep things like fun you know what i
mean i don't really want to like bum
people out i knew we were just talking
about like people dying really and stuff
like that but you know what i mean uh
but you know i try to keep things like
kind of fun and like because i don't
want to really
look it's like my whole
many of my jobs like are all to do with
like people true crime and people
murdering each other and stuff so it's
like a lot of times
you know i kind of want to keep things
fun too but well the weird thing is like
for fun i just i want to watch horror
movies
even though you'd think that i wouldn't
want to watch that like i'd want to
watch something else but i don't know
horror movies and like sad music like
cheers me up zach anderson that's the
other zach the other zach
there's a gay strat is it there's a gay
zack the straight tag well and zach with
an agent zach with a k yeah yeah yeah
i'm going to just assume that the the
new zag is the straight zach he go who's
that i do like to say so he knows he
knows who the saints are
yeah
i mean would you like that would be
really funny
the uh people were talking about
um
uh
marilyn manson earlier on and um he was
him and uh dude
trent rezner were living right outside
the french quarter on esplanade or
esplanade during the time i'd hang out
there all the time we'd [ __ ] run into
them
boy that was a [ __ ] weird time but um
manson
mentions a lot of new orleans a lot in
his [ __ ] book i recommend it what he
says about it is good is accurate
but it turns out that when we came here
our good friend dimitri and knows him
his friend is friends with him because
you know
marilyn manson's from here but they kind
of grew up together a dj friend
and um you know it's just kind of funny
it's a small world and the scene isn't
that big
if you move around enough and you
[ __ ] hang out with all the old djs of
the that era they all knew each other
you know
so that's true he he showed up on the
national [ __ ] stage and [ __ ] but he
was local here he was just a local guy
we know a lot of them like that brian
yeah
zach says uh hey speaking of beetlejuice
i'm imagining you meant beetlejuice even
though i get it you're drunk you can't
type
is it true all 80s houses were white and
pink and blue and had flower patterns no
that style is uglier than the 70s to me
um honestly more more [ __ ] i saw in the
80s was a lot of wood paneling wood
paneling um kind of let not leather
furniture but like vinyl fake leather
furniture yeah um a lot of glass and
chrome
if it was brass if it was an expensive
newer house yeah everything i mean to be
honest
when i grew up like most of our [ __ ] was
left over from the 70s so all of our
[ __ ] was like green shag carpeting and
uh yeah yeah so i'm saying wood paneling
a lot of 50s and 60s and mustard colored
uh beanbag chairs ultimate [ __ ] like
that macrame the ultimate 80s decor is
like the
the interior decors
from the houses that were shown in
robocop one
that's the way your house would have
looked in the mid to late 80s if you had
a lot of money if you were six if you
were
working at you know if you were an
executive working for some [ __ ]
general motors or something up in
detroit it would look like remember
what's his name the the guy who made
robocop the the the young corporate
executive was coming up i forgot the
name of that damn character they show
him back at his house before he got
blown up with the he's hanging out with
the [ __ ] girls
coke and [ __ ] yeah the inside of his
house that is the ideal [ __ ]
yeah
upper
mobility upper middle class [ __ ]
80s house chrome silver white gray
mirrored walls mirror stuff like
mirrored panels on the walls
everything's square right they
yeah the only thing that was missing was
a patrick nagle on the [ __ ] wall yeah
but that would have been there my best
friend in high school had one of those
on her bedroom wall yeah you can get
those not the
not the rio one but like the but one
that looked very much like the rio one
like the one on the cover of rio
um the duran duran album in case you're
yeah in case you're not old but if you
were real cool it would look like
something about a damn robocop
but my house i was just watching a video
earlier today which was only like nine
or ten minutes long uh from a channel
called i think it's called retrospective
right or it was something about like um
what furniture what houses used to look
like back in the old days and they had
one that was like i bet you had all this
house stuff in your house in the 70s or
something like that so i was like okay
i'll i'll bite and like every single
thing in there i'm like yep we have it
yep we had that too yeah i got a picture
of me i got
i got a pizza
i got a picture of me on my back resting
coming back from basic training on a
couch and [ __ ] one of the subscribers
that's your grandma's couch he [ __ ]
nailed it everybody's grandma
everybody's going to have the same couch
and it was well there weren't that many
there weren't anything i mean it's like
you basically bought your furniture at
like sears or pennies or something like
that and so now like every time i watch
some like retro stuff if i watch stuff
that was made back then or if i watched
stuff like nowadays like stranger things
or something like that where they're
trying to like recreate it i'm just
always kind of like oh my god my aunt
had that couch or like you know what i
mean it's always yeah or it's like oh my
mom had those dishes yep you know yeah
and the couch they got it right it was
almost western looking it was a white
couch with [ __ ] orange [ __ ]
patterns on it and [ __ ] laminated
wood there was no
it was [ __ ] funny man because it was
the end of the cold war now the cold war
was still on actually the time the photo
was taken and it was communism versus
capitalism but they looked a lot alike
they did capitalism just looked like
high-end communism man if you just said
that back then oh they got mad back
there but when you went into a
department store it was the same [ __ ]
over and over and over and everybody had
the same [ __ ] over and over the same
dishes and couches and it was an
industrial strength capitalism one size
fits all boom you know it's like
everybody had [ __ ] but it all was the
same [ __ ]
and then they would encourage people to
pack their houses full of little
knick-knacks and they'd have shelves a
little [ __ ] garbage and [ __ ]
especially like old people like boomer
bling and [ __ ] pre-bloom boomer bling
just put a bunch of [ __ ] in your house
let it pile up little statues of crap
you know they they were big into that
[ __ ] crazy
and then my grandma's house was like
that it was just nothing but plates and
[ __ ] little collectors things and
little figurines and [ __ ] little
things on little tiny shells you got to
install little shelves to put [ __ ]
little things and trinkets on it when
she died all that [ __ ] ended up on a
down front [ __ ]
law and the garbage can and got it
but that was like her treasure
but it's just like
because they didn't have
internet
so what did you buy you just bought
little trinkets the [ __ ] they there's
it was a [ __ ] man they get you to buy
anything back then camp guys said our
local sears was cool had a garden center
where they sold lawnmowers yeah ours did
too and a tire center and they sold the
boy scout uniforms and lots of stuff
like canteens mess kids yeah i think
when i was in girl scouts because i was
in girl scouts when i was in the fourth
grade um yeah i think i got my girl
scout uniform at
it was either sears or pennies i can't
remember but yeah they had like a whole
section in the back where you could buy
like all the like brownie uniforms and
boy scout and girl scout society's
function was to sell you trinkets and
junk back then and technology that you
didn't need and you never had no use for
it it was weird
the other zack says watching winona
ryder play a mom slowly losing her mind
and stranger things is something else
yeah i mean honestly
i'm just really glad that she got that
roll because she's [ __ ] great in it i
mean that's like really really good
casting i think no the couch wasn't
wrapped in plastic man i'll show the
couch one i have been to some houses
where the couches were wrapped in
plastic though absolutely
but our house it wasn't but we did have
my grandma's house you did have the
front room with the tv and that was like
the casual room and then there was like
the formal living room
where you weren't really supposed to
hang out in there
although we did later on
mike barrett says robocop one was the
[ __ ] best 80s action movie of all
times changed my mind he goes no i'm not
going to change your mind i'm not going
to change your mind no i don't disagree
it was up there it was up there
i mean
robocop was the craziest one and the
most accurate as how insane
the 80s were the outer edge the cutting
edge of the 80s were [ __ ] insane
toxic waste [ __ ] planned obsolescence
[ __ ] they talked about the whole
thing corporate greed and [ __ ]
backstabbing [ __ ] uh
[ __ ] disintegrating [ __ ] detroit
all that [ __ ] was accurate yeah
uh [ __ ] happening during a deer in a
crime wave
uh
experimental technology mixed with
[ __ ] criminal activity it was yeah
that's that's exactly the way
cutting edge [ __ ] 80s was
it was insane
all right so can we actually get to this
episode
okay
zach says i also thought it was kind of
funny how the dad's name in this episode
is johnson but the dude playing him the
actor looks suit looks like a super nice
jewish boy ish
attraction the jewish man
you and you're attracted to the cute
jews he did kind of i mean like i don't
know but yeah he did kind of for those
of you who are new to the show uh zach
is sucking he's irresistibly attracted
to uh cute jewish boys is what he said
men i'm gonna call him boys but you know
he likes getting yeah don't say that
yeah that has a whole different kind of
taste like these are underage they're
not underage he's just like you know
young
jewish kind of guys
you know they're more trustworthy i
guess those [ __ ]
they're so innocent right innocent and
dirty
well i don't know about that i mean
that's what he's after you think i think
so
i kind of like nerdy too well i mean it
depends it depends on what kind of nerdy
it is brainy nerdy i like i also like
brainy but it depends on what kind of
brainy and dirty it is too i don't want
to be like
i don't want to be like uh hanging out
with one of those people that's brainy
and nerdy but then like well actually is
every second yeah i mean you don't want
to be with one of those kind of people
yeah but yeah we even know who you're
talking about
yeah you know yeah i know exactly i'm a
little mad
[Laughter]
oh actually man matt get the [ __ ] away
okay
yeah
i mean
that's what i mean he's not young
anymore well that's what i mean he's
probably our age probably no he's third
mid-thirties now
okay but yeah i'm just saying i don't
like i said i don't have a problem with
like smart or nerdy or anything like
that because i'm into that too but
yeah just don't use it to like lord it
over other people i don't like that i
don't like it i don't like arrogance or
well some people use it to compensate
well yeah that's exactly why but that
doesn't make it any easier to put up
with even though i know the reason that
they're doing that that big pretty chick
that looked like a model who died the
brain tumor was his ex
they were well they broke up after she
then she died but that was his
girlfriend
it was funny because he's five feet tall
and she was like six one
yeah i mean i don't even i think he's he
was five feet wasn't he i have no idea
yeah
i'm pretty sure he's shorter than i am
and i'm pretty sure way short yeah i'm
only five fifty five or three maybe
all right so are we finally gonna talk
about the episode let's [ __ ] do what
you gotta do do what you gotta do oh may
i'm looking at your legs your legs get
building up you're looking good
can we can we focus or ain't gonna focus
focus on that ass he can't focus
[Laughter]
all right go ahead all right so today we
are talking about finally we kind of
talked about earlier echoes of the past
i kept wanting to say echoes from the
past but no there's another episode
that's called echoes from the grave yeah
which is a different one so that see
that's my theory
is that the makers of the haunting had
you know those uh magnetic poetry things
like the little uh kids that you can buy
and they're little magnets and you stick
them on your fridge and you can like
change all the words around i kind of
feel like they had that but like a
paranormal version so they're just like
echoes grave demon like all this others
and they would like just move all the
words around i kind of feel like but
yeah so this is called echoes of the
past this is season four
episode eight
so
we're talking about
libby and shawn johnson and yes those
are their real names and both of them uh
turn up on the show
so they had actually lived in fort
lauderdale florida which is about what
about four hours south of here something
like that so down by miami
and they moved to chester vermont
in 2005
with their two daughters grace and willa
couldn't really tell how old the kids
were
i don't know eight-ish something like
that
so
libby is on there saying man this house
and like i said i've seen the real house
um
the house that's on the show is like a
lot nicer than it the house that's on
the show is like all brick
and the one the real one is more
i don't know if it's wood but it doesn't
it's not brick that's for sure
so she says uh the house needs at least
200 000 worth of work just to make it
livable i'm not really sure what her
definition of livable is
but i've seen the house and i'm just
like yeah it was probably like in pretty
bad condition because like i said i
looked it up on zillow and it was built
in the 1790s
uh you know it's a big house and it has
like a mother-in-law apartment and stuff
like that but it's been renovated so far
but it's not like you know it's not
super in good condition so she says it
needs two hundred thousand dollars worth
worth of work just make it livable
sean is all about it though he's like oh
we're gonna fix it all up but we're
gonna i was just like okay well your
money
so they buy it
now libby decides to go back to work i
mean obviously because now they need
extra money uh and i'm assuming that she
was being a state stay-at-home mom like
prior to this so she gets a job as a
secretary at the elementary school which
if it was the one that is on the same
street that they were on uh is like
literally three houses down
now sean actually manages runs owns
something a car dealership but it said
he largely works from home and i was
just kind of like can you run a car
dealership from home i guess you can
but i mean as long as if you have other
people managing it i guess you can yeah
yeah that's okay got people out on the
lot runner yeah yeah
so uh so the house actually undergoes 10
months of construction or renovation
now from what i could determine for some
of that time the family actually
remained in their two-bedroom apartment
like while all the because they couldn't
really live in it like while the [ __ ]
was going on
so one day on her lunch hour libby comes
by from work and to check on what's
being done in the house now one of the
workmen has found this kind of like
cache of like old photos and documents
and stuff like that behind some boards
in the attic either behind the wall or
the ceiling or some [ __ ] like that they
were like tearing some stuff out and
they found a bunch of stuff back there
now this is dating from like civil war
era or maybe a little after that so
she's like super she's like ooh neat and
she like you know gathers it all up and
keeps it because she thinks it's like
really interesting
so march of 2006
the family move into the house now the
renovations aren't quite done yet but
close enough you know what i mean
now sean and libby are very very excited
about moving into the place but the kids
particularly grace
uh don't like it they say it's too big
and it's too scary we're not having it
and so there's that
now the girls have actually been
sleeping in the parents room because the
floor in their room isn't done yet
now the first thing pretty much that
happens is that the little girls are
sleeping like on kind of like a palette
or something like that like on the floor
in the parents room
and
grace sort of wakes up and leaps up from
the floor and starts screaming at the
door like get away get away get away
like that
now later she said they said she was
freaking out and uh
later she said that she saw somebody
coming into the room
what they said it was was like a man she
called it strange looking eyes i don't
know what that means because i don't
know strange looking is a pretty vague
term yeah um but yeah she said a man
with strange looking eyes was coming
into the room like coming at her and it
scared her and she was like yelling at
it so there's that
now at first like i said obviously they
just think oh she was having a nightmare
and they just kind of like write it off
later that same night though at least
according to the show
they all start hearing or at least libby
and sean start hearing like doors
slamming yeah
now sean goes out to check
but nothing is amiss like nothing is
weird it's like he goes out in the hall
and he's like i heard doors slamming
like in the hallway but none of the
doors were slamming yeah the way they
show them in the episode is they
standing there in the hallway hearing
doors slamming looking at the doors and
none of them are opening and closing it
was creepy in the episode
yeah that would be pretty weird if you
heard like doors slamming and it sounded
like it was right there and then you're
standing right there and nothing is
happening that would be pretty creepy i
would imagine kind of checks out with
some of the more credible cases i heard
like auditory i don't want to say
hallucinations but auditory phenomenon
yeah that's what this would be because
he's like they very clearly it was just
one time
and then another time and then it
started doing it like a bunch and he
just like went out there and he's like
what the [ __ ] and he went like all
around the house and he's like i ve we
very here clearly like heard door
slamming but we didn't see any door
slamming so it was a little bit weird
so he goes back to libby and it's like
yeah nothing's going on
now libby finds it particularly weird
that neither the girls like i said they
were both sleeping in the same room with
them they climbed up in the bed at this
point like after they had like the whole
man cam and coming into the room
experience
and they didn't wake up though even
though they said it was really loud like
all the door slamming and stuff like
that but the little girls like didn't
wake up through that whole thing which
seems a little strange so libby thought
it was a little strange
so a week later
oh thank you put more uh ice in there
just dies okay
so the girls room is done a week later
like i said i'm pretty sure they were
installing a new floor so that's what
they were waiting for so a week later
you know the girls move into their own
room so libby's in there reading to them
you know before they go to sleep or
whatever now afterward
now grace
was like i said on this show
she was maybe eight or nine i'm thinking
at least the actress playing her they
didn't have the only people that were
talking on this show like in real life
were the parents and a couple of the
paranormal investigators or at least one
of the paranormal investigators
so
grace apparently hears a little girl in
her room giggling
and maybe maybe not sees two ghost girls
like i said grace is not on the show so
i don't know what she saw exactly
but they on the show they portray it's
like she hears like two little girls
laughing and then sees two little ghost
girls
now shawn the dad
also apparently hears girls giggling and
it wakes him up like so he thinks it's
the kids but he open he says as soon as
i got up and went to the bedroom door
like my bedroom door and opened it
the voices stopped and then when he went
and checked on his daughters they're
both fast asleep so it wasn't them
so at that point he's like okay well i
just thought maybe i left a tv on or
maybe i was dreaming or what the [ __ ]
ever like he didn't really want to like
deal with it
now the next morning libby goes into the
room to wake the little girls up and she
sees like a puzzle
done like on the floor of the girl's
room even though the previous night
grace had been like man i hate puzzles
and i don't want to do one
and grace is also still asleep in bed
even though it's time to get up for
school like normally like her sister
willa had already got up and got dressed
and was like ready to go and everything
so libby wakes her up like what the hell
and gray said oh last night there were
two uh what she called fairies in the
room
and they were the ones that did the
puzzle she's like i didn't do it
she also said that the fairies played
with her all night hence why she was
still asleep i guess because these
fairies had kept her awake all night so
libby asked what do the fairies look
like and grace said well they had white
dresses and white stockings and they had
ribbons in their hair
and then she says
and i know people that have kids that
like their kids say creepy [ __ ] like
this
uh apparently grace said they live under
the tree in the yard
like out the window like when she looks
out the window she's like yeah they live
under that tree i'd be like yeah i would
[ __ ] a brick if my kids said that that
that's super super creepy but yeah it's
like well i know that kids say creepy
[ __ ] like that all the time and it
doesn't necessarily mean your shit's
haunted but yeah that's that's what she
said they live under the tree in the
yard
now one night it gets kind of chilly
outside
um this is vermont
uh so i'm guessing it's kind of cold out
so sean decides he's gonna make a fire
in the fireplace and apparently this
first time he's done this since they've
moved in because i think when they moved
in it was spring so i guess this is like
fall now
uh so he starts to make the fire and
grace flips the [ __ ] out she says you
have to put it out put it out it's gonna
burn the whole house down she says so
she was just like not having it and she
was beside herself
now a few days after that libby's
putting laundry away in the girl's room
and then she also hears the giggling now
at first she thinks that it's her kids
grace and willa she thinks they're in
the room or hiding or something like
that
but she goes downstairs and she finds
them they're actually way downstairs
like at the kitchen table coloring
so it obviously wasn't that
now grace has drawn a picture of their
house on fire
and uh libby is actually pretty
disturbed by this she's like why would
you draw something like that
and then grace says i'm afraid that you
and daddy are gonna die in a fire
because that's what happened to the
fairies mom and dad
again i would [ __ ] a brick if my kid
said this to me because that's pretty
[ __ ] creepy
it's like that it's like the two little
girls from [ __ ] um
shiny
when they showed it in the episode
that's kind of what they were i kind of
yeah i thought about it too that's
definitely what they were homaging i
think
they weren't they weren't as creepy as
that but because those little girls are
creepy come play with us
forever and ever and ever
[Laughter]
yeah if you read the book then you'll
know the whole secret behind all that
[ __ ] i know but that makes it that makes
it less scary too i feel like that's me
camp guy said i would check my smoke
detectors
well yeah
so at this point libby's like okay maybe
this house is haunted even though she
said that she was like real skeptical
and scientific and normally wouldn't
believe in that kind of thing but she's
just kind of like maybe there is
something to this
so she takes all the photos and the
documents and stuff that she found to
the historical society
now the guy there uh can't find any
particular evidence that there was ever
a fire on the property
but
they do find this weird picture
and there are
the guys in the picture are like
veterans from the civil war it's
apparently um what it is it's like the
50th anniversary of like the battle of
gettysburg and so these are like the
guys that had fought in it and they all
came to this like get together and
they're sitting there so it's all a
bunch of old dudes
now in the picture
behind the old dudes
are two little girls with white dresses
and stockings with ribbons in their hair
that's him now the historical society
guy said look how weird like the little
girls look in this picture like they
don't belong there he i think he said
something like oh they just like looked
like they'd been dropped in there like
they weren't really in the picture or
was just like added later or something
like that
um blackrock said is this the one where
the dad sleeps in the kid's room one
night and sees the two fairies and he's
freaked the [ __ ] out yes it is yes it is
hey pokey's on the show he's walking
around pookie's on the show
[Music]
no she's like no i'm not i'm gonna go
tear some [ __ ] up i'm gonna go tear some
[ __ ] up
she came up to me but she didn't want to
relax no
she wants you to like stop she wants you
to stop and go like go brush her chaser
she wants me to go in the in the living
room and throw throw to mouse throw the
throw throw her chicken yeah i got a
little chicken in the mouth
and a little square it's a little square
pillow
and she catches it it jingles she's like
come let's throw let's throw stop
talking to the lights cause these are
just lights to her she doesn't yeah she
doesn't get it yeah uh eraseo a says hi
tom and jenny everyone it's been a while
since i've been able to catch a live
stream but i love these haunting mondays
who is this
thank you a razor a rezzo a rizzo okay
yeah i remember mike said what year did
this happen uh 2000 what 2004 2006 2006.
you're way off no 2005 is when it
started no that's when they bought the
house they didn't actually move into it
until 2006. okay
so
yeah so there's this whole thing uh yeah
zach said those girls in the pick look
so badly photoshopped yeah they did
so yeah they're trying to make it look i
don't know what their real photo looks
like or if there even was a real photo
i'm just going to buy what they that's
the thing about a haunting haunted will
tell you a good story but they won't
show you the actual source material so
it can't yeah it's like let me see this
picture like did those little girls
really look like they didn't belong in
the photo like they're just like hey
ghosts or whatever because that would
have been creepy
the best series for showing the actual
source material so far
is paranormal witness paranormal witness
will show you the actual photo although
that got like stupid yeah that got
stupid it's like look there's a werewolf
outside my cabin
no there's not that was like two or
three it started to go down pretty but
that first that first season of
paranormal witness
was pretty solid
danny rowling said i don't know why the
mom asked the old guy who the girls were
as if he would know because he's old
it's like weren't you alive during the
civil war who are these people but yeah
so there was that
so so yeah so the little girls
apparently like look odd in this photo
like i said i don't i can't really speak
to that because i haven't seen it in
real life i think they photoshopped the
girls from the actual
episode well obviously that's what they
did for the show yeah i'm just saying i
don't know it probably didn't look that
good they look good it never does that's
why they never really show it
so then later on libby shows grace the
photo
and grace immediately goes hey that's
the fairies like right there in the
photo and she's like that's what i
thought
now sean at this point the dad doesn't
really want to deal with it libby's kind
of scared but figures well maybe
everything will be okay because the
ghosts don't really seem malicious
and grace doesn't seem particularly
scared of them like she just kind of
sees them as maybe playmates
so they don't and they don't seem to be
doing anything like really [ __ ] up
like they don't seem to be like throwing
anything around or doing like demonic
[ __ ] or anything so they're just like
well maybe it'll be okay
so at this point like i said libby
starts keeping a diary of all the
paranormal activity that's happening and
she really like takes like i said she's
very scientifically minded so she's kind
of like trying to note every factor that
might be affecting what they're seeing
like what was the weather like that day
how was everybody feeling that day like
what exactly did you see and all this
other kind of stuff and then she's
trying to do all that and then sean's
trying to watch the game and he's like
shut up woman blah blah so that was
that was how all that happened like when
zach said earlier
so while that's going on though and he's
telling her to shut up because she's
watching because he's watching the game
um
him and libby hear a thump coming from
upstairs
so libby goes up to the girl's room and
she said she felt like she was being
watched like she was kind of like facing
toward the window like away from the
door of the room and she's like i felt
like somebody was watching me so she
turned
so she turned around
excuse me
and she said that she saw
a black
figure behind her
now
on the show they made it look like a
little shadow of like a little girl
i don't know if that's what she saw she
just said it was a black figure so it
might have been a full-size figure might
have been a man it might have been
anything but
on the show they made it look like a
little shadow of like a little girl
so she said she saw the black figure and
she said and this she actually did say
say this she said it moved faster than
anything else she'd ever seen she said
it darted under the bed
yeah
yeah she said that so she turned around
she saw it standing there and like
wigged out and she said it like went
like darted under the bed
so at this point libby's like [ __ ] this
[ __ ] i don't even care if it's like not
delicious or not this is scaring the
[ __ ] out of me uh so we're gonna get rid
of these [ __ ] ghosts because uh you
know
so she goes to a store this is this part
like i don't know why this made me laugh
so much but she goes to like um kind of
like a new agey kind of store
to buy some smudge sticks and she said
she was really embarrassed to like go
there and buy them and i love i love the
actor shout out to the actor that played
the dude the dude that was yeah that was
like the proprietor
[Music]
who looked exactly like yeah man yeah
yeah man like who looked like the the
quintessential stoner and it's just like
everything and he was just kind of like
what yeah you want smart sticks okay
whatever like he wasn't judging you want
the smudge sticks you want the bag
[Laughter]
got ghosts yeah no problem yeah it's
like wait it's blessing yeah sure this
[ __ ] happens all the time i just thought
it was funny because i was like
you know 99 times out of 100 you go into
a shop like that and just be like hey i
need some smudge sticks no one's gonna
like think anything about it that's what
they sell
that's what they sell and you're coming
in there to buy it so they're going
there i think i got some ghosts oh yeah
oh [ __ ] yeah everybody's got ghosts yeah
yeah here we go get that
on there
take care of them that'll that'll drive
them right out
i know somebody come see you to help you
that's that's you know that's what they
do yeah like i said no one's gonna get
there no one's gonna judge you or like
think you're weird enough i had that
[ __ ] [ __ ] near [ __ ] in
cambridge came
[ __ ] cambridge massachusetts
right there [ __ ] where you know
[ __ ] harvard is and everything they
had one of those shops
and [ __ ] they had all the kind of
like weird occult wicked [ __ ] and
everything in there [ __ ] we have a few
they were waiting for somebody that said
that they had a ghost yeah they got all
kinds of stuff oh yeah you got to go
home no problem yeah we'll give you this
yeah they had you know they're back in
the back in the [ __ ] um mid 90s
it may not be there anymore
well yeah like i said even where i grew
up in like stupid old daytona beach uh
for a little while like right a mile
from my house that i could actually like
walk to there was a little bitty like
little witchcraft storage just like that
that's got girls working in there yeah
okay
cambrielle [ __ ] one of the girls
she's a fan remember cambrielle she
worked fashion designer fashion designer
yeah you know who that is of course you
[ __ ] run into her all the time at
[ __ ] man ray
i bought some of her clothes okay yeah
gabrielle was like
she was like kaylee's size little bitty
yeah a little bit she made some
beautiful stuff like she was rolling
into like old like victorian medieval
stuff yeah
which i liked more than kind of like
gabrielle worked at one of those
one that the one that i used to go to
was actually owned by a wiccan couple
yeah they were slightly older yeah i
think they were a little bit older than
me but yeah they were like a they were
american she'll say some smudge sticks
and all that [ __ ] special magic
candles and [ __ ]
yeah is there anything to this
no
no but but here's the thing
it's just like with any of the religions
i mean i'm not done so i'm just gonna
say faith is very powerful
if you believe in something
your [ __ ]
energy can sometimes drive these other
energies away that's a good way to
[ __ ] kind of put it
yeah i mean so if you believe it and
sometimes it may have like what they
would call sympathetic sympathetic kind
of magic yeah sure or something like
that yeah but yeah so she goes in and by
sage and she said she was real
embarrassed about it but i'm like no
one's judging you it's fine
so then um and she said after she came
in and smudged the house like the the
dad like took the kids out it's like hey
let's go uh ride some bikes out of the
park so your mom can get rid of the
ghost or whatever i'm sure he didn't say
that but uh so she goes in there and she
does it and she said it worked
for a couple of weeks like they didn't
really have any activity for like a
couple weeks but then
grace ends up getting sick i don't think
it was anything serious it was just like
a tummy ache or some [ __ ] like that
and
both the girls decide that they want to
sleep in the room with their mom with
libby so shawn says okay well i'm going
to go sleep in the little girl's room
then like and he sleeps in grace's bed
now during the night
um apparently he wakes up and he said
that it felt like the sheets and the
blankets were like being pulled down
tight onto him so he couldn't move like
there was all this weight like somebody
was like
pulling him down like that
now on the show they showed a bunch of
ghosts appearing and asking him where
grace was and stuff it's like what the
[ __ ] are you doing in here we just came
in here to like play with your daughter
and now
your ugly ass is in here in bed and like
they got mad i don't know
um but i don't know if he really saw
that he did say that he felt like he
couldn't move because the sheets were
like pulled down like taut against his
body that's what he said
um he was yelling at the ghost though
apparently because libby heard him
yelling at the ghost and like came
running down the hall like why
what are you doing like why are you
yelling so like it it woke her up and
she came down like the hall to see what
was going on
so the day after that i guess that like
freaked him out enough and it's like
yeah he he believes it now so now we're
allowed to bring in the paranormal
investigators
so libby contacts isis investigations
probably uh you know in in hindsight not
a great name but you know
uh so it's a bunch of wiccans bringing
in the wiccans there's four of them i
think right three i think it was three
ladies and one guy sure it was just a
crowd of them it was just a bunch of
them bunch of wiccans
a gaggle a gag
yeah uh so they show up now libby says
that she's immediately impressed they
all seem to hone in on that tree in the
yard that grace had said earlier that's
where the fairies lived like underneath
that tree suggested two of them know see
i kind of thought that too because i
think they kind of let it slip later and
i don't know maybe i'm just like reading
into it but i think because in the on
the show
libby says to one of the wiccans like
later on oh those are the two little
girls i told you about
so i don't know if she and like i said i
know it's a reenactment so i don't know
how much of that is like [ __ ] real or
not but it's like how much of the
house's history or like oh my daughter's
seeing these two little girls blah blah
like how much of that did she tell them
ahead of time right so how much of that
could because i kind of feel like if
you're going to have paranormal
investigators don't tell them [ __ ] right
let them figure it out let's see how
psychic you are let's see how psychic
you are i'm not i'm i'm keeping my mouth
shut right i just want to see how like
psychic you are yeah but she said that
she was impressed that they all went to
the tree and they were like oh yeah some
bad [ __ ] like happened by the street and
like i said that's pretty much with the
same i mean they were assuming that
these two little girls were buried under
the tree or like they got killed or
something like that that's what they
were seeing
now there was a scene here where one of
the investigators justin
uh and i don't know if that's his real
name or not uh he's shown
hearing a male voice going stay away
which was actually like pretty creepy
that was a good moment
but he wasn't on the show so i don't
know if that really happened or if they
just added that because they wanted to
make it scarier it was scary though it
was good but i don't know if that really
happened
now another one of the investigators
whose name is angela she's not i think
the only investigator that was on the
show was the one that named patricia
like i said who the woman that they had
playing her on the show was like super
young and hot but then like the actual
woman was like older let's let's say it
that way i'm not going to be as mean as
zack and say she looked like e.t but
but she was like much much older than
the actress that was portraying her
so another one of the investigators
whose name was angela she sits down in
the girls room and she starts drawing
she said well my psychic visions come to
me like you know as visions so i draw
them and so she starts drawing stuff and
she ends up drawing a picture of like
two little girls that look very much
like the two little girls from the civil
war era photo which like i said
which would be really impressive if you
hadn't told her jack [ __ ] about this
house yeah and if it was really hard to
get information about the history of
this house because you can do that too i
know it was maybe like harder back in
like the mid 2000s but
you know especially nowadays you can
find out pretty much anything like i
said i found out where this actual house
was and looked at it
uh you know on on google uh street
street view so
i don't know i don't know how much they
told the wiccans like before they got
there so i don't know how impressed to
be about this that she drew like two
little girls and then the other psychics
also said oh yeah we also sense two
little girls but like i said she might
have told them that ahead of time i
don't really know now apparently the cat
toy and it's not like a toy for cats it
was a toy that looked like a cat it was
one of those toys i kind of feel like
there was a lot
it was a it kind of looked like a real
cat but like i guess you turn it on like
with batteries or something and it like
does real cat stuff like it goes meow
and like kind of moves and stuff it was
one of those
so that came on by itself and they were
like oh see that's like the good that's
the ghost telling us that uh telling us
that they're there like moving around
the cat toy or whatever
i wouldn't checked on gabriel
boy her [ __ ] site is huge
now i didn't know she was famous
yeah
damn
i mean [ __ ] i yeah i knew about her yeah
of course
she was in all the she was in all the
magazines yeah she was in all the that's
that she thank you how she looked when i
knew her yeah i remember that yeah this
is how she looked when i knew her like i
said she had all kind of like nice
clothes yeah but really really into like
victorian victorian medieval yeah which
i which i'm more into that she has a
huge sight it's spelled with a k yeah
cambria thank you camp guy yeah awesome
show awesome t-shirts got five shirts
now she was when she was at the club she
showed up [ __ ] that's how she looked
yeah this is it okay oh geez god damn it
what are you doing this is how she lived
at the club when she showed up back in
the 90s
she was cute gabriel
[ __ ] funny how that we brought that
up and and that we knew who that was
well yeah
you never mentioned her before yeah i
knew that was yeah like i said i think i
bought a couple of her clothes she hung
out on that race
she was cool she was cool yeah
um zach says hey i'm not mean shut up no
no i'm kidding i'm a [ __ ]
thank you very much
thank you very much bro yeah
danny rowling said cat version of a
furby kinda it looked like a real cat
sort of
like it okay it looked like like the
uncanny valley version of a cat like it
didn't look like a cat but it kind of
did but in a way that was kind of like
unsettling so let's say that
so the psychics are basically like
okay
you guys
have an ass ton of ghosts in this house
that's a scientific term by the way
aston yeah and as time a
and they and they basically say in a
very victim blamey kind of way
did you guys do a bunch of renovations
in here and they're like yeah she would
not have done this this is [ __ ] epic
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] epic you just yeah
in the episode the girl
the woman playing
the main wiccan when she goes did you do
renovations she goes yes we did and she
goes like
yeah she
it's hilarious i'm like don't you victim
blame yeah she's like what are they
supposed to do you couldn't live in it
and it's [ __ ] funny [ __ ] ghosts
they don't have their ethereal they
don't have to like worry about plumbing
you know the actress is hamming it the
[ __ ] up sure she's like you stupid [ __ ]
yeah she basically made a face like you
stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] why did you do that
why did you do you should have just like
lived in it the way it was
with no modern electricity or plumbing
i'm sure zach knows what we're talking
about zach go ahead and [ __ ] testify
[ __ ] put that [ __ ] in the [ __ ]
comment section her face is great her
face was like you stupid [ __ ] yeah it
was yeah yeah yeah it was [ __ ]
hilarious because we both laughed
[Laughter]
i was like oh my god that's so mean
like i said what are you supposed to do
like you should have known
should have known it's gonna stir the
ghosts up
you put in modern toilets in the [ __ ]
that's right
all of a sudden ghosts everywhere but
yes you brought this [ __ ] on yourself
that's yeah that's what she's [ __ ]
that's implied basically that's implied
brought that [ __ ] on you that's what i'm
saying i think that's what made me laugh
about
so after that after they made them feel
bad about doing renovations on the house
they just spent and i i should say too
that libby on this show she basically
says the renovations ended up costing
more than the house cost to buy
and i'm sure she was probably like
thanks sean
although like i said it looks like
they're still married so i'm not gonna
get too much into that but yeah cause i
think they i think they still live there
zach goes oh yeah oh my god that [ __ ]
perform performance was oscar
yeah he was he was she looked like you
you dumb [ __ ] you brought that [ __ ] on
your [ __ ] self i mean everybody knows
that you should have known everybody
knows that
you renovate [ __ ] in your house and the
ghost they just like
who's out of the woodwork yeah like
[ __ ] ectoplasm yeah yeah so uh so
yeah all the ghosts got stirred up she's
like you have so many [ __ ] ghosts in
here i don't even i can't even so
all the wiccans they're like okay we're
going to do like a whole magic circle
thing you guys know what a magic circle
is it's like oh it protects kind of like
a circle jerk [ __ ] zap i'll tell you
all about it it's like an occult circle
with less fluids
so so yeah so they're like we'll do that
like for protection or whatever and then
we're going to do a crossing ceremony to
make the ghost you know pass on to where
they're supposed to be now as i said i
kind of feel like this episode this was
kind of like a a happy fuzzy episode
because none of the ghosts were demons
or none of them like were kicking
anyone's ass or anyone none of them were
like all that malevolent you know what i
mean like i can see that
maybe i mean assuming all of this [ __ ]
is real but it's like
you wouldn't want your kids like playing
with ghost girls because you don't know
like what the [ __ ] they're capable of
and they could do like some
you know they could do some bad
supernatural [ __ ] but
i don't know it felt it felt like
nothing
the ghosts in this weren't mean they
didn't seem mean
they just seemed i mean it was scary
because it'd be scary because it's a
ghost but
they didn't really do anything like
particularly
malevolent or destructive or anything
like that which like i said it's kind of
a change it was kind of refreshing i
thought
um but you know i guess because they
were hanging out in the house and
they're like well they probably
shouldn't be here uh they're causing a
little bit of a disturbance so we're
gonna do like a crossing ceremony
so they do that now i don't know
i didn't really get a lot of feedback
from the actual people like what
happened like during this thing
but on the thing when they were doing
the crossing ceremony because they
always make it look like way more
dramatic than i'm sure it actually was
because i'm sure in real life they're
all just like standing around in a room
like chanting and like absolutely
nothing is happening
but on the show they always kind of made
it uh they made it so like they heard a
bunch of like thumping noises
that they couldn't really explain um but
other than that
it didn't really seem they didn't really
do any like wind or like demonic voices
or nothing like that it was just like
some thumping noises and then all oh and
then they had all the ghosts like each
ghost like the two girls came and they
kind of like hey here's these ghosts and
then
and then here's this civil war soldier
that hasn't played into the story at all
and then like yeah hey here i am
then like he goes up into this guy with
a weird head movement with his weird
head movements yeah yeah so there was
that whole thing so each ghost kind of
came and got its here's like this random
old lady that we haven't talked about
and it's like there she goes up into the
sky and everything like that yeah
they're like kicking them the [ __ ] out
of here
like get the [ __ ] there
all right fine we're going we didn't
like it here anyway since you got like
modern plumbing [ __ ]
yeah
[Laughter]
but yeah so other than that everything
seems to go off without a hitch most of
the ghosts most of the ghosts not all of
them they said well yeah most of them
are gone i'd be like most of them what
do you mean most of them
they said get get rid of all of them i
hired you to get rid of them but so most
of the ghost goes cross over into uh
what they call the summerlands the
summerlands which i guess is like the
afterlife for wiccans but the thing
about it though i and i said this when
we were watching the show too i'm like
[ __ ] summerlands i want winter lands i
don't want to go to like the afterlife
and it'd be [ __ ] summer all the time
[ __ ] that [ __ ] i'm not going
i'm not going if it's like that
so after that uh the wiccans did the job
gotta say everything returned to normal
now there's a little
little coda at the end here a little
while later they dig up the tree
in the yard the fateful tree
because they're going to put in an
addition on the house
and when they
dig up the tree underneath it they find
like a burned
brick foundation like a little bit of a
burn brick foundation some burned wood
beams and some burned clothing
as though there really had been a fire
at some point even though they couldn't
really find any record of it like i said
it might have been a really long time
ago
uh they didn't find any bones so
you know i don't know if anybody's
buried there but it did look like at
least according to the show it did look
like there had been a fire just like the
little girl thought there was that's
what was underneath the tree was what
looked like the foundation of an old
house that had like burned down so there
was that they did find some merchant
now i will say okay
i couldn't find out much about this
house otherwise
now
i did find out what the actual address
of the actual house was but i don't
really want to say it on a public live
stream
although i will mention
that the show the episode
absolutely did
say what street the house was on
and the street that
they said that it was on that's the
street that it's on okay
so and it's just off hand like i don't
think most people would even notice it
because it wasn't like part of one of
the big main things but i heard it
because i was like oh did they just say
what street it was on i wonder if that's
real so then like i looked it up i'm
like oh my god it is so i found so if
you really wanted to and like i said the
names of the people on here are
absolutely their real name so if you
wanted to find this address you
absolutely could so i found it in about
five minutes and uh looked at the actual
house and as far as i could determine
this family does still live there they
still own the house so like i said the
house was built in the 1790s now the
only other thing that i found about this
house which i thought was kind of
interesting
there is a forum called city data and i
guess you can go on there like whatever
city you live in like it had like
residents of that city can like talk
about like various things that are going
on in there so i found this uh the city
data forum for chester vermont which is
where this house is
now there was a post from 2016
and somebody claimed
that
they had just watched re-watched this
show
and somebody's car alarms yeah what the
[ __ ] outside this isn't a place where
car alarms that's the car who the [ __ ]
has car alarms and carl arms in this
area yeah somebody's car alarm was going
off so uh so somebody said oh i just
rewatched this episode the other day
like i said this was 2016 they posted
this
and they said oh well i heard that
shawn's
car dealership the one that he managed
wasn't go wasn't doing too well or that
they had some money problems or that
they were being investigated by the irs
or some [ __ ] like that and they only
made up the story about the haunting to
you know get some publicity and maybe
make some money off of the [ __ ] so
somebody put i don't know how they got
that information sounds unlikely but
like i said they put that on this forum
now i will note though that a couple
posts later
somebody replied to that
and this was back in 2016. i haven't
seen anything since then and they said
no i spent a lot of time in the house on
the street that it's on
um and they said more than 10 years they
didn't say they lived there because like
i said i'm pretty sure that original
family still lives there but i'm
assuming that these people are like a
friend of the family or a relative or a
neighbor or something they said yeah
i've spent a lot of time uh you know
more than ten years uh i've spent a lot
of time in that house and it absolutely
is
haunted
now this person also claimed that four
people had died in the house three of
whom were murdered
now i was like oh i'm absolutely gonna
look that [ __ ] up yeah how could they
know um i couldn't find anything about
that now i did find like a pretty famous
murder well that's it's not famous but i
mean in the town it was famous there was
kind of like a big murder that happened
in uh chester vermont in 1929
but as far as i know it wasn't on this
street it might have been somewhere else
there wasn't like a huge amount of info
about it so i don't really know sounds
like a wild claim to me that's what i
mean because i was like if some if three
people got murdered like i don't know if
they were three murdered like at the
same time or if it was like over because
the house has been there for like
hundreds of years
so it could have been three people
murdered over
you know centuries which is correct okay
strange though [ __ ] you'd have to dig
that [ __ ] up
and who's digging up these records to
prove that three people four people died
there over the hundred and some odd
years i'm not saying it didn't happen
i'm just saying in my own cursory search
i couldn't really find anything like
nothing came up
so
but i mean you might have to like dig
way deeper because it might have
happened like a long time ago i don't
know like i said i didn't have like all
day to like look into the [ __ ] but i was
curious so i kind of started looking at
people jump to the conclusion that well
this is a bad house so therefore murders
happened
i don't think that's necessarily
the case you know i mean [ __ ] you
might just have a bad house
maybe not because somebody was murdered
there just a bad person lived there at
one time and
their spirit or something is connected
to that place in a weird way you know
that they don't they won't believe it
they're just a bad person it may not
have anything to do with murder
you know yeah i don't think i mean like
i said i don't usually believe in that
kind of like oh ghost like that keep
that hang out there like after they die
because why the [ __ ] would you want to
do that but
but if that was true it's just kind of
like that doesn't necessarily mean that
they got murdered in there maybe they
just really like that house and they
don't want to leave the average
homicide's mundane doesn't even really
involve evil people just dumb people
fighting over something and both of them
kind of bad
and then you know who
a [ __ ] more told tortured and
conflicted person
might be a better candidate
for a haunting that would make a [ __ ]
bad house than say a murderer
just some dude who's [ __ ] crazy you
know
crazy and constantly worrying and
[ __ ] self-torture kind of
constantly punishing himself and he's in
his own living hell or in his and then
when he dies he's like in the undead
he's like the he's like in his own hell
in a parallel universe
and it's like his astral like he's
projected slightly he's connected to
that area
punishing himself
is more likely
well i kind of feel like like i said i
don't really buy into the whole thing
but if you do buy into that whole thing
then you could think well if this person
doesn't think they like okay just
hypothetically they don't
think they deserve to go to like a
better like a higher plane or whatever
and so they're kind of like further
punishing themselves by hanging out in
this house and like staying here and
then they're just getting angrier and
angrier somebody who can't resolve
whatever and more resentful sure yeah
and i kind of feel like there is a lot
of um you know people that do kind of
believe that about ghosts it's like well
that's why they're hanging out because
they have like a bunch of unresolved
issues whether it's somebody that they
have to like tell somebody about
something or whether they don't think
like i said they don't think they
deserve to like pass on to like
something better or blah blah so they
just think they're like hanging out here
because there's all kind of like issues
that they haven't worked yeah i've
always kind of imagined it as like the
soul of of of it of a [ __ ] crazy
person of an insane person
who's [ __ ]
punishing themselves
more than anything else
because
even the evil can [ __ ] resolve their
issue
after
after death you know what i mean and go
to wherever
they go you go into the afterlife and
then [ __ ] maybe punish themselves
and then then get over that and then
just continue on and [ __ ] reincarnate
in some way like uh
and so in christianity and islam and
judaism well judaism not so much but in
christianity and islam
uh you if you commit evil you have to be
punished in hell
it's they say it's forever and ever but
then like in the apocrypha in
christianity and in judaism well no it's
actually not forever it's just that
you're in a timeless state
um it's you go in and then what they're
talking about then they make references
to kind of like some of the ideas that
come from zoroastrianism where you die
you go to you descend into a
basically a self-inflicted hell to burn
off all of your impurities until you
[ __ ] have paid for what you've done
and resolved what you've done and then
you're free
you know because you paid for it
it's probably a situation like that
in other words a time of penance
and then you're free
it's like a reset button
so um
could be that
could be that a bad house or a haunted
house is a person who has
not willing to go through
the [ __ ] burning off of impurities
phase so they're kind of
stuck slightly in the astral world they
don't want to go to resolution so they
just
they're out there out of body they're in
a rut yeah
torturing and punishing themselves with
fear
a good movie that kind of shows this
would be the frighteners
where a dude dies and he's like no this
couldn't have happened to me no i'm
still alive i'm gonna move back in with
my wife and [ __ ] michael j fox like
no no no don't do that you gotta wait
for the light to come back and then go
to the light type of deal oh no no no
it'd be somebody like that
but worse maybe
someone who's afraid to move on
maybe they're thinking internal
punishment that type of [ __ ]
perhaps so yeah zach says the summerland
sounds like the name of a retirement
community in florida it probably is uh
to be honest they're probably one of
those out there
but it also does kind of sound like an
afterlife kind of situation too yeah
danny rowling uh danny rowling says uh
black ghost what you replace the formica
cabinets aw hell no your husband's ass
is mine tonight yeah that's what i mean
renovating renovating don't be [ __ ]
changing don't change don't don't pull
that shag carpeting out change the ship
the ghost is really really used to that
don't pull out all that wood paneling
yeah like i liked that there i liked it
but yeah so oh and i want to say too
also
uh the the wiccans
on this show i don't know if they're
still around but isis investigations is
apparently no longer a thing or they
might have changed their name uh they're
because their domain name is now for
sale somebody posted a link like back in
2016. i don't think i have to do
something that's what i mean and i wrote
on my notes i said uh their domain name
is now for sale though i can't imagine
who would want it maybe they want that
for 20
no they're selling it for
fourteen hundred dollars
the domain name
so they might still be around but
they're not called the same thing
because like i said that's not a great
name thank you very much thank you thank
you thank you orezzo question for tom
you talked about bad houses before how
do you define bad house my husband's
culture has a similar concept i don't
believe in hauntings or ghosts but i've
always find found that interesting
well i guess she didn't hear the
original story about the bad house maybe
not because like she hasn't been around
in a while
when i started the ets out of the army
and get out my best friend was only like
um
he etf at the time his name was eric
eric
he was etsn only five days before me
and we
and i had a girlfriend
in boston going to university there and
he had lived there before so we already
had this plan look man we'll get we're
getting out around the same time
when we ets and get out of the army
we'll move to boston together
all right great
so um
he ets first and hung out in the
barracks for like about a week which we
could do that back in those days because
the barracks was kind of empty and then
we moved out together and we left
we the day we left
fort campbell kentucky a mass shooting
happened at a damn [ __ ] um massage
parlor which changed the destiny of
[ __ ] and we left and [ __ ] watched
all the all the cop cars descend on that
damn shooting we found out about later
what happened dude found out that his
wife was working that [ __ ]
massage parlor and he killed her and a
couple of other girls and some other
dudes and then shot himself in there i
remember that yeah okay
that was the day we got a that was uh
september 24th 1994. i remember that
case yeah
so uh we drove
all the way to boston
we already had a house [ __ ] lined up
and moved in there
that house is over 100 something odd
years old and it was in arlington
massachusetts right outside somerville
right no no
right outside medford is where it was
and i found it before i forgot the
address but i found it on google earth i
remember i could find it again i know
where it is
moved in there man and [ __ ] it had
just a a
a bad feeling about it like you were
being watched and it was very oppressive
and um
you didn't want to [ __ ]
be by yourself in that damn house
well we started dating girls we lived
there for [ __ ] almost a year
and a lot of weird [ __ ] happened in
there
we only paid
first last months and deposit for that
and no one ever collected rent from us
we didn't know where to send the rent so
we were in there for almost a year we
didn't pay any money
i don't we don't i don't understand what
that was
[Laughter]
then later the [ __ ] the house sold to
somebody else and told us we had to
leave they gave us notice and we so we
left we didn't even know where anyway
we were living in there and um a bunch
of weird [ __ ] had happened much good
[ __ ] happened too you know [ __ ] we
were hanging out with [ __ ]
john's wiz from sleep chamber and all
the barbiturates and we had all kinds of
[ __ ] wild ass [ __ ] parties in
there with hot fish strippers and [ __ ]
[ __ ]
i was
we would be dating these girls we took
over the whole house when we first moved
in there the realtor said we only had
the bottom floor but then we found
as weeks and months went on we just took
over the [ __ ] whole house it had
[ __ ]
uh three fl two floors and then an attic
apartment and i was living up in the
attic apartment
felt like you were being watched in the
house
your girlfriend [ __ ] would have to go
take and go go take a leak and she would
want you to walk you to the [ __ ]
bathroom and wait outside for a while
she was taking like nobody wanted to be
in the house by themselves i'd [ __ ]
walk in and [ __ ] walk up on eric
sometimes he'd jump sky-high and i said
what are you scared of and he never
[ __ ] admitted it a bunch of weird
[ __ ] had happened in the house
he never [ __ ] admitted that he was
afraid of that place until we moved out
and i said you were scared of the house
weren't you like yeah it was it says why
because it was a creepy house this house
was haunted wasn't it and he goes whoa
no no he because he was a real rational
dude he didn't believe in that [ __ ] and
so the house is haunted [ __ ] dude
needs it but what the weird thing about
that is that nothing ever moved
so i'd already seen the poultry guys and
it was moving stuff it just nothing ever
moved in the house
never saw any apparitions never heard
any voices
just the feelings of being watched kind
of an unnatural stillness
and bad dreams you'd have real bad
dreams
you'd have bad feelings
and kind of almost kind of like visions
in a weird way you're like oh
you didn't i don't want to open that
door for some reason i'm not going in
there that kind of [ __ ] you'd have the
weird mental image
of something you know
being bad on the other side of the door
there's nothing you could really prove
to yourself
i wonder if it was something to do with
maybe
i don't know was it some kind of like
weird
sound thing or maybe some kind of
i don't know i don't know there was one
time where [ __ ] i felt like i was
being attacked by something but i didn't
see anything i was just being attacked
by of waves
of fear and hatred
swirling around me
now see there was an episode of a
haunting which actually we watched but
we haven't done a show about it
um about that house where
all the women that went in there said
they felt horrible horrible like
overwhelming depression and sadness yeah
like they couldn't explain it yeah
it's like that
but
i never really could prove it to myself
but everybody felt that
way it had anything moved
i would have known i was like yep
i but i never
whatever it was it wasn't poltergeist it
wasn't
wasn't anything that i had seen before
so i just kind of put it in the category
of bad house
i wouldn't even really say it was
haunting because
i didn't see any apparitions or hear of
anything
and it didn't communicate in it yeah
like not like anything was trying to
communicate yeah it was just a bad house
a real bad house
now i kind of wonder like if you
looked into the history of it like if
something like really really bad
happened there and you're like picking
up on that i don't know i'm almost there
feelings of dread at the time i didn't
want to know
whatever it was
there was something bad in there
so i can describe it yeah
kevin donovan said i lived on cape cod
for a year and a half salem is the mecca
for wiccans and nature people if you
want to have a fun halloween you have to
visit salem massachusetts yeah i have
been wanting to go to salem
massachusetts for halloween that's where
campuses and ages that's where cambria
was from she worked in one i would love
that she worked in a shop there near the
[ __ ] witch museum
and then she worked at another shop i
believe later on over there near
cambridge
that they had back then yeah zack says
what was the address for that house
um i don't remember it off the top of my
head but i can find it again
yeah you'd have to like look if i know
where it is i mean it was a while back
so it might look different now well yeah
it's it was an old house it's [ __ ]
funny because it's behind a liquor store
now because the city grew up around it
and you go down to main street and then
it was uh
man
not arlington
i don't remember the name of this
you had to get off on the red line the
[ __ ] i think not davis but the very
last
stop you had to get off and you had to
walk and you had to get a bus and then
you had to [ __ ] go down you had to
take the bus
to my to my house i had the damn t-pass
that included
train and bus though
i didn't have a car at that particular
time there and really owning a car at
boston and though those days just was
impractical well like there's nowhere to
park it yeah i mean like big city like
boston new york stuff like that i mean i
wouldn't even bother where to park it
with a car yeah it just seemed so much
cheaper just to buy the damn t-pass sure
go anywhere just seems like a hassle
well like i said you i mean in florida
you can't get away with that because
the one the everything's too far apart
the public transportation is uh
atrocious and two like everything is too
far apart everything is just kind of
like
all the [ __ ] you want to go to is like
20 30 miles like so you absolutely need
it's all country like if you live in
this like if you live in a big city you
don't really need a car but down here
yeah what's funny is that like people
that live in those areas constantly
trying to dictate to the rest of the
[ __ ] country how things should be but
they don't live in the same reality that
we live in
the distances between things is [ __ ]
vast and you can't put
you can't put [ __ ] public
transportation because it would go broke
it would go broke you couldn't connect
at all i mean we have some but it's not
great
and honestly like i grew up in daytona
and like i
didn't have a car for a really long time
because i couldn't afford one so i did
actually have to take a bus but
you could kind of get where you were
going but it would take like an hour an
hour and a half minimum
and you'd have to like walk like half a
mile too so there was that yeah but zach
i'd have to find it on google earth
again because i can remember the path
that i took i know where it is on the
map
but remember this was uh
1995.
so yeah that was a very yeah and i was
only there for i was there less than a
year
and if i heard this it wasn't really
even on the street it was in a it was in
a circle
or a cul-de-sac
it was a main street never in between
two damn
a laundry mat and a [ __ ] girl and a
[ __ ] dime store what do you call it a
[ __ ] liquor store was a look like a
dab driveway that would go up into
behind the alley and it would open up
into a circle
that had about six or seven houses from
the 1800s in there
like
1870s
they weren't behind
the storefronts at the time that they
were built they were out in the middle
of the country
but they connected the ball that way
they were old they had the basements
were all stone
like big old [ __ ] stones and [ __ ]
the basements were very creepy in that
one house
but i would say they were 1870s
and the floor plan didn't make any
goddamn sense everything was victorian
you had to walk through everybody's room
to get anywhere
and they still had 1800s early 1900s
bathtubs and showers in them
and a lot of really nice molding and
stuff everything was wood
kind of everything would creak you know
wooden floors there was no carpet just
wood floors
but the wall layouts didn't make any
goddamn sense
and it was uh it was like something it
was like lizzie borden's house if you
remember those little borders like that
well you can still go to that house as
far as i know yeah i'm always kind of
like interested in that because
that just goes to show how people's
lifestyles have changed so much
since that time which wasn't really like
you know in the grand scheme of things
wasn't really that long ago
but
yeah the fact that so many houses from
that era
are
they didn't really have a huge concept
of like privacy or
i don't know man it just seemed like
really weird how
how you had to like walk through like
people's rooms like to get to other
[ __ ] [ __ ]
well hey rebecca you just got here you
just got here and we just already like
we
just finished talking about the show
uh
let's see uh mike says i'm sorry i'm
drunk yeah okay
i
mean danny rowling said i've been to the
salem witch museum as a kid
i've been yeah i've been wanting to like
go to salem maybe one of these days like
when i have enough money like that would
be like a good place to vacation because
i've always wanted to go there because i
love all that kind of stuff
so
i don't know maybe one day when i can
afford it
i really like
honestly the only places that i've been
in
um
kind of the
i don't know the the northeast of the us
i've been in new york city several times
i've been to
philadelphia once
i've been to
baltimore once
and that's about it that's about it
i think
i don't think i've been anywhere else
and then i've been like out west a few
times
uh you know i've been to santa fe and
denver and [ __ ] like that but that's
pretty much it
mrs evans already already said my house
is like that every room has a door to
the next room i read it was for heat and
cool air control i guess it must have
been but that must have been like really
really weird i can't imagine
i just can't imagine what it must have
been like to be like uh hey go to the
bathroom just don't mind me
walking through you're walking through
your room like to go to like the
bathroom yeah yeah
well that's why we started to move on
different floors yeah each floor was
really only suitable for one person yeah
yeah in the modern era that's what i
said that always kind of fascinated me
about how
different our lives are now it is like
how people's lifestyles are so different
nowadays than they used to be let's see
i'm gonna find that place i'll tell him
okay go ahead and keep doing the [ __ ]
rebecca said uh lol my timing is awesome
as always yeah i mean well it's not your
fault you're like way on the other side
of the world so
you know like i said we've been on here
we talked about the show well we didn't
talk about the show for probably like
the first 35 40 minutes because you know
how we do but
i think we've act we actually talked
about the show longer than the actual
show yeah probably did yeah i think we
usually do that but i mean they're fun
though these are fun to do i like them
but this episode this is a good episode
i liked this episode because
one well hi pook
she came and rubbed against my leg
i like this episode because um
one it wasn't they didn't feel the need
to like oh some of the ghosts are
malevolent i liked that
um and i liked that wiccans came in and
saved everything which you know which
you don't usually see on these shows
i kind of feel like
because we've talked about this before i
kind of feel like maybe one of the
things that kind of pissed me off about
the later haunting episodes is like you
said they got a little churchy now i
don't know if it was the same company
that was doing it well hi okay
i don't know if it was the same company
or if
it was
a different company or was the same
company with different owners or what it
was but it did seem like it was getting
churchier as it went on which is
you know they bring in the priest and he
fixes everything but some of the earlier
episodes yeah they brought in priests on
some of them but this one they didn't
even like talk about any priests or
anything they're just like let's call
the wiccans and then i don't think she
said let's call the wiccans she was just
like let's call paranormal investigators
and they happen to be wiccans and they
came in and they fixed it
apparently so
i don't know
i don't know
are you finding it yeah i think it was
off mass f
okay
yeah mrs evans already party said i love
these shows these are fun i really like
doing these these ones on the and the
sidetrack shows are like my favorite
ones to do just because they're not i
mean this one i do do some research
ahead of time because like i said we
watch the shows and i take a bunch of
notes about it and then i try to like
find out stuff about the house otherwise
um so i did do some research about this
place like to see if i could find some
other [ __ ] about it and like i said i
did find out where it really was but i'm
not going to tell anybody because i
don't want anybody like because the same
family lives there evidently so i don't
really want anybody bothering them but
um
but so i do do that but
other than that i mean these are like
pretty fun to do they're like pretty low
stress you know
uh eresso says that's interesting that
being watched sense of something bad on
the other side of the door is how my
husband describes it too yeah yeah yeah
yeah honestly it's like i've lived like
i said i've lived in some purportedly
haunted houses in my time probably the
most um prominent of those being my
grandfather's old house which is not
there anymore it was torn down and made
into a frat house actually
uh for the college that was it was embry
riddle
um but he had lived there for many years
and i
lived there with my family off and on
like over the years and i loved that
house it was like really really cool i
think it was built in the 1910s 1920s
something like that so it was like
pretty old but i always like really
liked it
now my mom and all of her siblings of
which she had seven
um all grew up in that house and they
all
had a bunch of stories about how haunted
that place was they said oh my god like
the the covers used to be torn off
they're uh torn off them like in the
night they used to hear like footsteps
like walking back and forth across the
roof all the time and all this other
kind of stuff so
me like being a kid growing up there i
was like super excited about it i was
like woohoo ghosts all right and it's
like i wanted to like experience it but
i never did i never did and honestly
like even in that house the house was
creepy
but
i never felt
uncomfortable there i never felt like it
was haunted like to me and i was always
i know that's weird but i never i was
always kind of like disappointed
i always kind of like wanted it to feel
haunted to me because all of my you know
my mom and my aunts and my uncles you
know told me they'd grown up there and
they said oh my god all this like crazy
[ __ ] like happened when they were
growing up
and
i was like i just kept waiting
because i lived there for quite a while
like off and on but nothing ever
happened and i never felt weird there i
never felt scared i never felt anything
like that like i said matter of fact i
loved that house i thought it was like
really really cool but
unfortunately it's been torn down which
really makes me sad like when i think
about it and honestly like when
uh still to this day even though it's
been
i don't even know how many years it's
been since the house has been torn down
but
uh i still have dreams about that house
nowadays and if any of you have read
my book
which is my novel which is called
bellwether
um
when i was writing it i i set it in that
house
actually i've said a lot of my short
stories in that house but that novel in
particular i said in that house
particularly
because i used to love that house i
thought it was like so cool but
it's gone now which bums me out
i'm having a hard time because i can't
put the damn
get a street view
mike says when's the next giallo review
jenny i think i'm going to do one in
september i can't remember what what i'm
doing because
a couple days ago because i try to keep
like those kind of reviews i usually
like do them a month out i don't always
do the ones that i think i'm gonna do
because
of various things like maybe something
else comes up or
you know that just disappears off the
streaming service or whatever
but
i think i might do
um
the case of the scorpion's tale maybe
but i'm not really sure i think it's
going to be sometime in september though
probably or or i'm going to do another
one in september it might be that one
i'm kind of thinking that
that that'll probably be the one
um let's see
mrs evans already party says i lived in
a house with a very happy spirit it was
weird and awesome at the same time i
always felt watched but protected
and i was completely unafraid in the
dark
see that's cool though
i'm seeing streets that i recommend or
that i i recognize the names i'm coming
up on it
eventually i should be able to find it
i'm trying to get a damn street view
i'm looking for the little court
that it was in
i'm just following the road
i may not be able to find it within the
time frame of the [ __ ] show
but all this stuff sounds familiar
i mean it's been a while so it's been a
while yeah hancock
um
it take me time to find it now i think
bedford
man it's been so long since i've been
down there you should have prepared i
should have prepared and you should
probably be okay look i'm not
i know the general area but it looks
like they've actually
changed some of the streets yeah i mean
like i said it's been a long time so
they probably don't yeah because i i
found it before
a couple years ago on the show and i
found it quickly
i'm having a problem finding it they may
have actually
for all i know purchased that area and
[ __ ] torn it down i mean a lot of the
clubs that we used to go to no longer
exist
rathskeller no longer exists
man ray no longer exists i mean
where uh man ray is is the bookstore
of all things which probably out of
business but what's wrong with the
bookstore it's probably out of business
by now i don't know there's still books
there's still a bookstore in downtown
sanford
yeah look up
uh ian england said i swear there's a
little gremlin at my work because i'd
find i'll find tools that i was looking
for in places i thoroughly scoured yeah
uh rebecca said drinking at 9 30 i'm
assuming she means 9 30 a.m yeah might
not be the wisest thing for me but while
you all get drunk i can hit the
medicinal cannabis exactly
we'll see there you go
uh mrs evans already party said sorry
your grandpa's house got torn down yeah
i'm still kind of like bummed out about
it i really i don't know i really really
liked that house
um that sucks i like houses better than
i like most people yeah i feel that
um kevin said tom do you lift at a gym
or at home that's an easy question for
you to answer yeah i got i got a gym
right there just in the next yeah right
in the next room like on the other side
of this wall yeah uh he's got some gold
gym free weights gold gym free weights
yeah he's got a whole thing over he's
got a bench and everything so like now
sometimes when i'm in my office i hear
him going whoa yeah yeah yeah like in
the next i'm like uh i am trying to make
a video in here
okay you uh ready to get some hot dogs
is that a sexual in you yeah yeah
no i'm just kidding uh yeah we're going
to make some contacts
for dinner yeah we've been on and whoo
an hour 44 minutes
like i said we've done like well yeah
well these are five everybody these are
fun these are fun
so yeah now tonight we are probably
gonna watch because i told him i was
like look i have so much work to do
tomorrow so let's not do a movie that's
like really complicated that i need a
lot of uh
that that's really long or that i need a
lot of time to
analyze and stuff so we might do
since we did king kong yesterday we
might do son of kong or maybe mighty joe
young we'll see uh which one we feel
like and maybe which one is shorter so
uh so yeah so come back tomorrow uh
evening and we will be doing a movie
review matinee show
so thanks for hanging out with us this
evening and thanks for all your super
chats and all your comments you guys are
awesome and we will see you guys again
tomorrow
bye